welcome the best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can watch just
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go along
with this video check out the link in
the description below alright so today
is bonus day number six and we're gonna
learn how to become better investors
[Music]
sports cards are exploding gym I need
everybody who's listening right now to
really go to stock ex and eBay and see
what's going on I've been investing in
sports cards for eighteen months last
April and May and June I bought 50
LeBron rookies and now they grade them
you send them to a company they say if
it's a perfect ten a nine and eight
about 50 / 50 ends at $1,050 a piece now
they're selling for 4000 a piece Wow
Kyra give me a brief primer not knowing
a lot about this if I want you to buy
tell me what do I do
you go to Google and you search sports
cards you know why are sports cards
going up like you type in questions on
Google then you go to ebay completed
items and you type in athletes Lamar
Jackson rookie card and you hit you
could search and then you get completed
items and you can see for the last two
three months how much they've gone for
let me give you the comp there I wanted
to do it and I sucked I miss made a huge
mistake I didn't take action because I
liked Lamar's game I didn't think he was
gonna do it either this year but Lamar
Ricky's in perfect tens were thirty five
dollars going into the season now
they're three hundred last year I did it
with giannis I bought him at 180
they went there at 800 now here's so you
go to ebay and stock acts and you look
at the prices and you look at completed
auctions and that gives you you spend
four to ten hours on that looking up
athletes most of the cards your
listeners and I grew up with aren't
worth anything because it was during the
junk waxey era where they made a million
of these now they make limited numbers
of them and the vintage graded stuff is
going great but there's three reasons 45
year olds are now having SEP now have 7
year olds so they're reliving their
childhood gambling you can buy a $200
pack of cards right now that's how much
they can be now gym 200 for 1 pack
but you can pull $150,000 Luka or Zion
so gambling and then finally you know
sports cards have a lot more volume than
sneakers so we have an entire generation
of teenagers who are now in their 20s
that grew up flipping Easy's and Jordans
who now if they think that Lamar Jackson
is gonna be the guy they go out and buy
five hundred two thousand four thousand
Lamar rookies and make $100,000 in nine
months there's a lot of talk about
control in the book what is the one
thing that you want people to understand
about control and you feel out of
control they feel they don't understand
the stock market like what's the one
message you want to you want people to
take home around control I think it's
that you have to become an owner not
just a consumer you have to take a
percentage of what you earn as
simplistic as it sounds and automate it
so it comes off the top of what you earn
there's a gentleman used to work for UPS
names Theodore and theater Robinson was
this guy who never made more than
fourteen thousand dollars a year and yet
he retired with seventy million dollars
and gave away 35 million was a lot how
did he do it he became an owner his best
friend said to him listen to me the most
important thing in your life is we're
gonna put a 12 tax on Eagle is your
wealth tax
I make 14 thousand a year goes we're
gonna make you wealthy with this tax
it's not a government taxes tax for
yourself so we're gonna take 20 percent
of what you earn and put an investment
account let it build up he said I can't
afford that he goes once it's automated
you won't notice that's all he did that
made him seventy million dollars so it's
like people have to understand that no
matter how good you're in business we
all need a second business with no
employees and it takes very little time
something that once you do your homework
should take you you know 15 minutes to
an hour twice a year to rebalance
perhaps what would you tell the startup
entrepreneur who maybe is just getting
started maybe he still has a full-time
job and it feels like every dollar that
they're making they're just trying to
build their business at the moment they
haven't cashed out yet should they be
invested into the business should they
still be saving some went to the market
what would you tell that person I think
you have to put something outside your
business because what's the number one
rule of investing that even idiots
understand don't pull all your eggs in
one basket right and what
90% of entrepreneurs do because of the
illusion of control they go I'm gonna
put all my money in my business don't
get me wrong it's still a great place
for your money of your time with your
energy but you got to take a piece of
what you earn and you gotta bet on some
other entrepreneurs and get outside
yourself specifically and if you look at
you know somebody like Warren Buffett
I'll sell you you know look he said my
all my wealth as a result of a couple
things some good genes and compound
interest and living in America
so if all you do is get compound
interest on your side the game changes
if you take a 19 year old kid that's got
a little job and you say look I want you
it sounds like a lot but I want to put
aside $300 a month let me show you why
three two bucks a month set aside throw
it in the market average market returns
been 8% spend 10% of a hundred years but
most recent you know thirty years eight
percent so let's say you get the average
return that compounds that kid who
starts at nineteen where three hundred a
month can stop at 27 he's only done it
for eight years
never put another dime in and he's only
put in twenty four twenty eight thousand
dollars but that'll grow to 1.8 million
without putting him in a diamond that's
the power of compounding 28 grand 1.8
million if his best friend starts at 27
when he quits and the best every single
year all the way to 65 and he puts in
the same three hundred dollars a month
he puts in a hundred forty grand and in
that time he's got four hundred thousand
dollars less money so it's not the
amount of money it's the amount of time
time is your greatest friend here and if
you get in the game you're gonna win and
you need to get the game now not wait to
your business to success I'm big on
diversity or very big like patient of
knowing how knowing how to adverse by
well is more important than almost
anything people don't understand this
without an evergreen principle yes
that's it evergreen principle and the
reason I'm saying that the way it is
it's almost like a casino making its
money okay okay
the way that you do it is you get an
edge so now when you have to make a bet
I've got a bet against the whole world
the world has view on something is
reflected in the price so when I think
something is attractive or unattractive
that means I have to bet against the
whole world and whether that's right or
not that's difficult I get it right you
know more
and then I get it wrong but I'm gonna
get it wrong sometimes and so when you
can take a lot of different bets what
you can do is like the casino
you'll get your average that your bet
would be but you'll reduce your risk
event one of those tables not being the
table that's paying off and so that
margin that so I can reduce my risk
without reducing my return by knowing
how to diversify and I'd say that's
particularly true important for for the
people or listening near investors
because what they've got reduce risk
without reduce in return that's right
that's the specialty that's right
elaborate a little bit more if you don't
mind on that so we do some risk without
reducing the return because a lot of
times if I'm reducing the risk it means
my returns also going Lord what you're
saying no wrong thing would not even
reduce them to return right I mean
that's a high-paying skill set yeah it's
the most important thing that you could
start off doing if you have a number of
equally good likely bets but they're
uncorrelated like the casino you know
one table is going to get me a margin
like this but take another table and it
makes me a margin like this but I might
have volatility about those let me take
all those investments that I think will
make 10 percent so that's my return but
they're uncorrelated with each other
that means I'll still get to 10 I don't
lower my 10 but my diversification means
I lower my risk so I improved my return
to risk ratio ah is that an art that you
can teach oh yeah
yeah I wrote about it in there's a what
I call a section in this book the holy
grail of investing it's a three pages
long
and it explains basically this important
thing because when that epiphany
happened to me and how I would do it it
changed everything by being able to do
that because how old where I can improve
through diversification I can improve my
return to risk ratio by a factor of five
so by
diversifying okay the return relative to
the risk I can keep my returns the same
and reduce my risk to one-fifth if I
know how to diversify well and that's
what I'm explaining it's not all that
complicated it's simply explained in the
book but in any case that is the holy
grail of investing okay that's a big
thing if you start to know that that's
what you're going for it changes
everything and it's so important for the
average person is listening and don't
let me explain why that is because the
average person who's listening too many
people think that they can go into this
very difficult zero-sum game of betting
against the consensus and be right you
know what I mean in other words investor
says I'm gonna go in the markets I'm
gonna make money betting against the
consensus and be right right because the
consensus is built into the price okay
okay that's what's up so it's think of
it as like going to a horse race and
there's handicaps okay you're not going
to pick the best horse and you're not
going to pick the best company a
terrible company can be a better
investment than a terrific company a
terrible company could be a better
investment just like the terrible horse
can be a better because the odds that
are changing let you go into that and
that becomes the longshot but because
the long shot is going to pay off 25 to
1 right if he comes in that you could
just as likely bet on the long shot as
the leader and it's going to be equally
likely that you're going to make money
right otherwise you otherwise the market
would be doing the opposite well the
market is like that right in other words
if everybody believes that something's
going to be terrific
ok then everybody's betting on it and
its price is high so it's not what's
best necessarily it's what's best
relative to what's in the price what's
discounted in order for you to win in
the game like
gonna go in and pick what's a good
investment hey you are playing against
others you have to realize that because
that's it's all in the odds it's like
when you go to the track you're going to
have to play against the handicappers
okay so it is very difficult for you to
beat me or to beat others who were put
in 1,500 people and hundreds of millions
of dollars into how to win in that game
right and there's a lot of people and I
find it challenging I find it difficult
so it's difficult to win in that game
it's it's difficult to win in that game
individually by placing the bets it's
difficult to win in that game it's more
difficult to succeed in the markets than
it is to succeed in the Olympics okay
people but people don't realize that
they think I'm going to go have an
absurd okay but there are more people
trying to do it in the markets that are
trying to do it in the Olympics and so
nobody would say I'm gonna run and
compete in the Olympics when you realize
how difficult that is okay but you can
diversify well anybody could diversify
well so if we look at what the world
will be like in five years or three
years or one year okay like we're coming
in the presidential election we have all
these things going on okay you want to
bet on it okay wise guy give it a shot
that's is that is that easy that's what
you're okay well the only way I can do
it is I need to diversify my bets well I
wouldn't want to concentrate on any one
of those and I tried it I'll take like
the casino I will take I'll take that
bet and I'll take this bet and I'll take
a bunch of those bets but for you was
the average investor you're probably not
going to even be able to pick which
horses got the the edge what mitt
relative to the handicappers okay and so
diversification that is the thing that I
would say particularly for anybody it is
the most important thing it's if you
know how to do that well so that's why
I'm saying you know that page those
couple of pages here was something I
wanted to pass along to you you'll see a
lot of people will say that's a boring
formula or it's an outdated you know
you'll be in the industry so this whole
bad versification is a boring formula
with cetera I'm just going to say I went
from nothing you asked me okay I
my dad's a jazz musician middle class or
lower middle class family I had nothing
other than parents who cared me and I go
to a good public school and that was the
only thing I had and if I took that and
I say okay here I am with the things
that has happened over the markets and
making money and here at building a
business and so on there was there a
limited number of principles that I want
to pass along to people because I think
if they can get those principles that
that would be extremely valuable and
this is not boring so when I come back
and you say okay that arkad Lajja was
not boring that was a very successful an
exciting arc in life and this is one of
those principles so if you take
diversifying well how to diversify well
please go understand that principle it's
only a couple of pages please go
understand that principle because when
you have savings and you think how much
money do I need for my kids education or
my retirement or whatever it is and so
on and if you don't know how to do this
well you're risking a lot and if you do
it well and so on it produces an
enormous amount of opportunity what's
what's the value of a stock that never
returns capital to its shareholders I
don't know because the only way you can
make money is if somebody else is
willing to buy that position at a higher
price for some emotional reason perhaps
or for some you know foresight that
maybe the company will return capital
one day and I think of it you know what
when you learn as an investor over
multiple decades is the only thing that
matters is free cash flow that's it
there is no other reason to own a stock
and with that philosophy it brings you
into a place where you focus on a
company's ability to generate
incremental cash flow because just
owning a dividend paying stock is not
good enough because you know let's say
we find a stock today that's paying a
three percent dividend yield and
tomorrow because it's forecast for sales
get cut in half the stock drops on 50
percent now it's yielding six percent
I don't want to own that stock either so
my tests in this index that I've you
know created with what see Russell looks
at the balance sheet every year we test
to make sure that the company is viable
in its ability to generate cash this is
extremely conservative investing this is
for the long haul
these tools are not for as you're
suggesting for spicy you know the hot
stock does your I've done that I've been
there you know let the young legs do I
have zero interest in that I don't care
what the hot new stock is you know when
a company comes public I won't own it
either it's got to prove to me over
multiple years that it can continue to
generate cash before it even fits in to
what I'm doing so I'm really boring and
I like it that way I'm guessing it came
from your mother but what would you say
was the best piece of financial advice
or business advice you ever got in your
long lengthy career when I was seven and
my brother was five she take us to the
bank with her you know to because that's
where you would buy bonds back in those
days you could actually buy the
certificate with the coupons every six
months you clip them off she'd say to
his boys never spend the principal only
the interest I had no idea what she was
talking about that's all I do today in
my world you never touch a principal you
adjust your spending habits your gifts
to charities your use of capital based
on how much you can generate from your
portfolio I view my portfolio and my
trust and my positions as a chicken on a
spit dripping cash everything has to
generate yield whether it's a fixed
income position or in equity it has to
it the only reason it can be in my world
is generating capital back to me I take
that I disperse it the family lives off
that the charities I've committed to so
I'm always looking for a company that
can help me with my problem of
generating more yield everything that I
mean I can't even imagine buying a stock
that doesn't pay a difference why would
you do that what would it be the reason
you would do that I don't get it so to
me that means about 28% of the market to
me is just speculation a stuff that
doesn't pay a dividend is a speculation
it's not an investment
this car right here this rolls-royce
Wraith with freaking magic the magic
astrological zodiac sign built into the
ceiling with little sparkles dumbest
damn thing you could ever buy in your
life is a big expensive luxury car in
fact okay in my rant today I want to
share with you one of the things that I
did smart in my life was I never bought
these exotic cars that everybody seems
to go out and buy as soon as they make a
little money what I did was this I
waited I waited and I waited to ever do
it dumb thing like this nothing one of
the dumbest things ever bought in my
damn life okay I waited until number one
I didn't have to buy one and number two
until it didn't matter I just got my
financial statement in three months the
first three months of this year compared
to last year a double a double you
understand what a double is a double
means I can do stupid ok look once you
make enough money to where you can blow
four hundred sixty one thousand dollars
and it don't matter then go do it okay
until then until then do not waste your
money I'm sorry this car was only three
hundred eighty four thousand dollars I
didn't want to exaggerate to you but I
think they added some stuff to this bad
boy so look until then until then until
then don't waste your money on watches
and cars and bring out Briony suits okay
it's ridiculous you guys that are buying
twelve hundred dollar shoes stupid you
guys are buying two hundred thousand
dollar cars stupid you guys are spending
money on homes no offense but just
stupid you don't need an expensive house
you don't need a country club yet what
you need is paper you need money baby
you need network you need passive income
you need flows baby flows and flows and
flows
you don't need a Rolls Royce you said
that portfolio balancing is a waste of
time so what are John and Sally dough's
supposed to depends how much money you
have right so the best way to get a
return let's just say you have $50,000
in cash it could be ten it could be a
hundred but you know let's use fifty
first thing I would do is pay off all
your credit cards because that's costing
you eighteen percent that's what John
and Sally should do first most don't
write there's more credit card and
student loan debt relative to a personal
income there has ever been in the
history of the United States second
thing you do is you use the
transactional value of cash a lot of
people say you know you're losing money
to inflation when you just have cash in
the bank I completely disagree I can you
know I know I'm gonna be buying a bunch
of suit toothpaste for my family I know
toilet paper I know all the consumables
that I have I can take my cash and go
get a better value I can take my cash
and go to my store up yeah yeah why not
I mean how much space is toothpaste take
you know but you're gonna spend but
that's the whole thing the time it takes
just to figure out your budget it's
nobody does the time it takes just to
analyze your spending habits you can get
a better return and you'll end up with
more cash than trying to fight the the
John Paulson's of the world and these
guys who who have hundreds of analysts
who are working for them why would you
try to do better than them you can't win
you can't and now it's it's a hundred
times worse because of all the the
program trading but if you have enough
money that you have to put some of it
somewhere to park some of it somewhere
and hope to make a return on it where do
you put it you know what I do I don't I
don't think you have to make a return on
it because I'd rather sleep well at
night
you know I put it in cash literally now
obviously I'm in a different position
where I don't have to live off of the
interest pay me one basis point off a
gas right but at the same time the
having that dry powder if you will
available when weeks like today or weeks
like this week hit and days like
yesterday and today and you'll see an
opportunity you see an opportunity then
you're ready to take it as opposed to
saying I can't get out what am I going
to do and I'll tell you the other part
that's better you're gonna cut your
health costs because you're gonna sleep
a whole lot better at non sleep well oh
I sleep like a baby
biggest money mistake I made in my life
isn't
singing things that I don't understand
and we're just like stocks yeah
stocks I bought that I knew nothing
about that I heard on at CNBC I should
buy or haven't some guy the one things I
like about your real estate deals it's
straightforward it's it's it's simple
it's easy to understand if you present
me a deal now and I can't regurgitate it
back to you real quick in some simple
form I'm not investing in it I need to
at least understand what it is I'm
investing in yeah even if even if you
miss something you're willing to miss
something I miss something yeah I've
missed so many things yes so if I can't
understand it or it's too complicated
and I can't repeat it back to you pretty
quickly you lost me yeah what was so
what's the biggest loss you had in not
following that advice would you mind
when I bought I bought Yahoo stock at
about I don't remember 75 or 80 bucks a
share and I'm talking like when I had
about three million bucks I put like 800
grand in there and I think I ended up
selling it in like 17 about citigroup's
how would you buy that I think in this
70s or 80s I could exact car and then
like after I learned that lesson on 540
grand yeah they're not no no you lost
700 and then we'll give you two more
biggies second one I did is I bought
citi bank stock Sam Group stock at like
fifty four dollars a share
yeah 2008 which it was about seven
hundred thousand dollars worth of that
and I think I sold it at 250 two dollars
and fifty cents is when I finally sold
it because I heard they were going to be
the next day AIG yeah their work 200 and
a third one is stuff you talk about I
bought a residential real estate
property that did not provide any
revenue did not provide any equity for
me that was a what would you call it it
would be like a trophy property like hey
I'm a big shot the big-time about what
that wasn't that long ago either and
that was a property that I wasn't going
to use wasn't getting leverage out of
didn't generate revenue I didn't know
anything about the market I was buying
and I just wanted to look like a big
shot and I think I lost two and a half
million on
house and that wasn't that long ago
that's just a few years ago so I've
still made some mistakes in my life but
though those are probably the biggest
loss probably that house on one deal was
probably that house allows to the house
every night maybe I lost three million
now I've got a special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best live 30 questions
of the day it's not enough to just watch
a video like this you have to do
something and take action in your life
so pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets yet you can get them for
free by signing up for the series in the
description below here we go question
number one where do you need to do more
research number two what are the things
you understand that you can invest more
in and number three what are the dumb
purchases and you need to stop making
and if you're doing the best life 30
challenge with me give me a hashtag best
live 30 down in the comments as well so
I can celebrate you this isn't something
I talk too much about on the channel in
terms of investing I have my own
philosophies and strategies around
investing first off I believe the best
investment you can make is in yourself
as an entrepreneur as a human being to
get better to learn to adapt to grow
you'll make way more money in your own
company then you will by investing into
a stock market or real estate or
something else but if you're starting to
make money and you're keeping something
pulling off the table saving for
retirement whatever it is not that we're
really gonna retire I think if you're
really a true entrepreneur even as easy
as I have a back-up plan in case
something goes horribly wrong one of the
only true actual sources of passive
income is investing into the stock
market especially when you don't have to
do anything that's managed right if
you're not buying something that you
need to check in on all the time so you
can look at index funds write an index
fund just matches how the market is
doing and you know the markets going up
you're making more money and
historically the markets gonna go up
it'll have down periods but overall it's
gonna go up and you can just keep
putting money into that and it'll keep
paying you back when you don't have to
worry about doing anything if you're
managing an active portfolio then
there's a little bit more work just like
the advertising campaign but the idea
here is you're leveraging your money to
help you go out and make more money you
know before we were leveraging
are people to be able to be able to
bring more in for our business right so
just another way if you have some money
saved up you can use it to bring in more
money it's not going to be a huge return
on investment and I still think the best
bet is probably in yourself and your own
business but it is another way to make
money wisely if you want to join the
best life 30 challenge and get the free
worksheets click the link right here
below me or if you want more videos on
how to be a better investor check out
the playlist right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there